just when you thought the milk couldn't
get any worse
yes episode 4 the boys is here and if
you've ever wondered what it's like to
make out with yourself
just remember
[Music]
in this video we're covering everything
episode 4 the memes
the chocolate bars and even the
background actors
listen if you're ever in the mood for
another ramen joy
but before we get into it make sure to
like and subscribe or else
welcome to the worst dating site ever no
not tinder the deepest holding
interviews for his new wife
we'll see a couple of these women being
interviewed throughout the episode as
part of the church of the collective's
plan to clean up the deep's image
and get them back into the seven with
eight train now out and starlight
wanting out two
it's looking more and more like the deep
has a chance of getting back
back at the boys hideout everyone is
reeling from the events of last episode
stormfront's attack
ended up killing 59 people but the media
has spinned it to make it seem like it
was all
kenji's fault kimiko's soup terrorist
brother who was radicalized by the
shining light liberation
army and frenchie my dude you don't go
in for a kiss when your girl is mourning
deny homelander is pissed stormfront is
getting all the attention from the press
he's obsessed with being loved something
he didn't get as a child growing up as a
vaught science experiment he especially
craves the love of a strong
take-charge woman which is why he
gravitates toward madeleine stillwell
who he killed at the end of season 1.
now i got to admit at first i thought
this was some sort of dream or
hallucination
but homelander has a suit named
doppelganger morph into madeleine so he
can satiate his desire for
motherly love and milk precious precious
milk we last saw doppelganger in season
1 where he was used by madeline to frame
senator calhoun grace and butcher meet
outside a vigil for the 59
killed in the stormfront attack fun fact
these scenes were shot a minute away
from my home so i went out and snapped
this picture of what the real buildings
look like
grace talks about how she's haunted by
the victims of supes who just stare at
her wanting her to do something helping
butcher is her way of seeking
some sort of redemption she gives him
the location of his wife becca who's
currently locked away in a vat compound
with homelanders son
ryan they also discuss a quote second
tier soup from the 70s called liberty
who may
somehow be involved with susan raynor's
exploding head if you haven't checked
out my episode 1-3 video you'll want to
check that out as i go over who this
head-exploding soup could be
homelander and madeleine relax to a
romantic movie taxi driver
talking to me and in the episode trivia
it says that homelander finds de niro's
character travis bickle a role model and
if you've seen taxi driver that's
uh saying something i also couldn't help
but feel the scene where kimiko attempts
to assassinate stormfront is crazy
similar to
travis bickle's attempted assassination
of senator palentine
in both cases the assassinations never
occur homelander is pissed his identity
has always centered around him being the
face of the seven but that's slowly
being eroded if that's going to change
he'll need to
tear out the wii butcher tasks mother's
milk with going after liberty while he
goes after becca
if they can get more info on this
liberty suit maybe grace can pull some
strings and reunite him with his family
homelander nearly kills starlight after
her hesitance to kill
hugh last episode she ends up telling
him the truth that she loved you but he
broke her heart and now wants to blow
his face off bonus points if you notice
this takes place on the 69th floor
nice black noir gets more than eight
seconds of screen time using anika to
track down butcher
she works in crime analytics and you
might remember her from episode 2 of
season 1
being bullied by homelander we also
learn a very important piece of
information that black noir doesn't like
almond joys jeffrey
dahmer's chocolate bar of choice
starlight decides to come with huey and
mother's milk on their search for
liberty she's still apprehensive about
their decision last episode to release
the story about compound v
we risked our lives just to make the
world
way worse she doesn't want to be around
homelander or the vaught tower so she
comes along for the ride which includes
billy joel's
we didn't start the fire from an album
called get this
storm front a train finds out he's being
replaced due to his heart condition
potentially being replaced by shockwave
as long as he's not promoting
anti-toddler obesity this is really
setting him up to join starlight and the
boys who he previously tried to stop
from exposing vaude but now that vaught
has turned against him all
bets are off there's also a fun little
jab at apple plus and disney plus when
homelanders says
a-train will get his own show on vot
plus and we know we're in the south with
an anti-abortion suit billboard and a
homeland or confederate flag cape a
drunk frenchie opens up to sherry about
his love for kimiko
sherry's name literally means darling in
french and we first saw her in episode 2
of season 1.
she says to frenchie by saving her
you can make amends for all the people
you hurt
for those children that lamplighter
burnt
frenchie was a member of the original
boys under grace mallory he was
responsible for stopping lamplighter but
not before lamplighter burned alive a
bunch of kids
this of course was all covered up and
lamplighter would later retire from the
seven
making room for starlight to join we
haven't seen him yet this season but
lamplight will be portrayed by sean
ashmore which is kind of interesting
since in the x-men films he plays iceman
starlight and mother's milk have their
first bonding experience starlight was
never allowed sweets as a kid due to her
overbearing stage mom we also learn
about mother's milk's father a lawyer
who tried to bring down vaughn and
worked
so relentlessly he died of what my guess
is heart disease it's never really
mentioned but i don't get the feeling
there's
anything too nefarious here butcher is
able to secretly meet with his wife
where he learns she's been living on the
compound since the birth of homeland sun
rhyme the only reason homelander didn't
kill butcher at the end of season 1
was that she promised to kill herself in
front of ryan
and say your father did this to me if
butcher was killed we've seen how much
homelander yearns for the perfect sun
but there's only so many times becca can
threaten him with that
starlight and huey get it on there's
been sexual tension building but
starlight later tells huey that their
relationship can't continue
we can't afford to feel good or to feel
safe
or to let our guard down becca and
butcher also hook up and plan to escape
a plan that's short-lived when the very
next day
becca says she can't go through with it
exposing butcher's feelings towards ryan
he's a [ __ ] soup freak
at the end of the day becca can't leave
her son especially when it means he'd be
raised by vaught and turned into another
homelander
and then vaught raises him without a
mother right then we have homeland all
over again then there's two [ __ ]
[ __ ] in this world she believes
she's the only one preventing that from
happening
homelander outsmave on live television
when he's confronted with hashtag heroes
so white we already know what homelander
thinks about diversity
he knows about maeve's relationship with
elena a relationship which maeve said
last episode if homelander found out
he'd kill her but homelander seems to be
taking it really well
honestly mike i am really
really happy for you or not something
tells me this isn't the last homelander
will bring this up he winds up watching
a stormfront rally his blood boiling as
she continues to get attention
she's using anger and emotion to get the
people on her side
remember emotion sells anger
sells the enemy here are the soup
terrorists but the rhetoric here of
scapegoating a specific group of people
is highly indicative of what the nazis
did to the jews
in fact there are several connections
between stormfront
and the nazis not only is she a raging
racist
but the name stormfront also happens to
be the leading internet forum for white
supremacists neo-nazis and holocaust
deniers
we later learn that stormfront is indeed
the soup liberty who went mysteriously
missing for 30 years
after being involved in a hate crime
that was covered up by
vaude this could mean she's the daughter
or related to frederick vaught the nazi
who experimented on jews at the dachau
concentration camp and who would later
become the founder of vaught industries
stormfront also doesn't age just like in
the comics which starlight suggests may
be a result of continued use of compound
v
something she'd have access to if she
were connected with vaut homelander is
pissed at the amount of memes made about
him i've left a link where you can find
all of them in the description here's
one of my favorites this spurs
homelander to finally confront
stormfront and she knows exactly how to
push his buttons
this constant need to be loved by
everyone is kind of pathetic
this almost gets her lasered in two but
she says she knows what his problem is
he hasn't changed with the times like
she has a nod that she's liberty the
united states isn't some homogenous
group that once could be easily
manipulated nowadays not everyone is
going to love you
you don't need 50 million people to love
you you need
five million people [ __ ] pissed and
really she's talking about american
politics today
where it seems the loudest voices in the
room the ones who cater to fear and
emotion are the ones who get the most
headlines she has
five interns who she pays in arby's
cards to make memes
which does more damage than homelanders
multi-million dollar marketing team and
i'm just gonna come right out and say it
but i think homelander and storefront
are gonna get it on i mean he does have
a thing for older women and she's
probably like
70 plus now and here is where
homelander's character arc really
changes
at the beginning of the episode he
lamented how no one loves him anymore
and he wants to get that feeling back if
he can put the seven back in line and
become the face of it again
everything should be fine but when he
finds out that isn't going to be
possible his mindset completely changes
instead of wanting to be loved by
everyone he says
i don't need everyone to love me i don't
need anyone
this final scene where doppelganger
morphs into homelander was one of my
favorites in the episode it allows
homelander to express his own feelings
to his
literal self you're pathetic when he
says that he's not saying it to
doppelganger it's what he
feels about himself he's pathetic
whereas in the beginning he needed to
feel that love from madeleine stillwell
he now needs no one i don't need anyone
but myself if you thought homelander was
a piece of [ __ ] before
how about homelander who doesn't care
about anyone or anything he's not gonna
give a [ __ ] about anything anymore
the only thing that might possibly bring
him back to some degree of sanity
is his son but even that is up in the
air that's it for this episode breakdown
of the boys make sure to give it a like
subscribe and leave a comment below on
what you thought about this week's app
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you